the idea of slowing down the aging
process and living healthier more
productive lives is hugely appealing
it's led to a growing trend for people
looking to take control of their own
biology optimizing their bodies and
minds through biohacking
but how safe and ethical is it
and are there more natural ways of
boosting your biology
in this film we're going to hear from
both the biohackers trying to push human
health and well-being to its limits and
those taking more traditional scientific
approaches
dave asprey is an american entrepreneur
and the self-described father of
biohacking
i fully expect this is not a made up
number to live to at least 108 years old
unless something like a tree falling on
me takes me out a lot of people ask can
we really hack the aging process and we
are now on the cusp with
literally about 50
different innovations to control biology
of aging coming online all at the same
time and i have a hundred percent
certainty that within a few years our
new innovations that come in happen
faster than our aging it's certainly
true that the scientific understanding
of aging has progressed rapidly in
recent decades but why is that i think
one of the really big surprises that's
come along about aging is how malleable
it is
there are especially in animals and i
think what comes a huge surprise is that
sometimes the same thing will extend the
healthy lifespan of a fly but also of a
mouse
and what that's telling us of course is
that some of the underlying
mechanisms of aging that we're
interfering with
are in common between these animals so i
think that's why it's
aging has opened up really to research
in in recent years is the discovery that
we can use these short-lived things
where we can get the answers more
quickly
to understand what's going on in the
creatures that we really care about
particularly ourselves as the science of
aging and longevity becomes more
advanced we're learning
how to not just slow down
gradually the effects of aging but truly
reverse many aspects of aging we believe
the cells in our bodies
have youthful information when we're
born and over time they lose that
information
we've discovered that there's
information
in the cell to reset the system
in the way that you could reboot a
computer with fresh software for example
we've recently reprogrammed the eye of
an old mouse to be young again and those
old mice
get their vision back and that's just
the beginning i believe of being able to
turn the clock back literally to make
younger tissues in the body there are
several companies within the growing
longevity industry who are working on
developing regenerative therapies to
combat the diseases of aging one such
company is the levien who are
investigating how a protein found in
young blood might have surprising
regenerative capabilities our
co-founders were part of a team that
that really made some important
discoveries that young blood can
rejuvenate aged animals and vice versa
aged blood can accelerate aging in young
animals and out of that work they
identify this little known factor called
gdf11 that decreases with age and what
what we in other labs have now found
is that
very similar dose range of gdf11 can be
used to
treat and prevent
dozens of age-related diseases
this research which originally began on
mice is still in its early pre-clinical
stage any drug development process which
arises from it has to be thorough which
can take years
elevian estimate that they are about a
year away from beginning human clinical
trials
for those impatient to slow down their
aging process and not keen to take part
in experimental trials there are steps
that people can take in their daily
lives
in many ways our fate during aging is in
our own hands already
it's really clear that
if you can you should take as much
exercise
as
is healthy and also eat a healthy diet
and not eat too much
dr david sinclair believes certain
stresses on the body can actually be
good for longevity
if you do the things that trick the body
into thinking times could be tough short
bouts of
skipping meals so hunger fasting
but also losing your breath so running
on a treadmill doing a lot of heavy
weight lifting we also think that these
are
another way to
promote the body's defenses and the
combination of all of those things
actually is known to extend lifespan by
keeping people healthier for longer some
biohackers are determined to go further
and are willing to trial experimental
therapies on their own bodies
i decided that i wanted to try every
extreme intervention i could the stuff
that billionaires are doing so that i
could write about it and so that i could
benefit from it
i've had my bone marrow taken out spun
down to get stem cells and reintroduce
the stem cells throughout my body
there's 150 supplements a day that are
part of my regimen but no one really
needs to do that i am a guinea pig to
see which ones work
and i'm constantly experimenting there
are different degrees of of how far
people want to go to slow down their
aging process the most advanced i've
ever seen if you want to call it
advanced was
uh there are a few people that have
tried reprogramming their body with gene
therapy and giving themselves hormones
that are delivered by dna uh to me
that's a risk i i definitely wouldn't go
there because these effects are
irreversible and if there was
cancer-causing issue
then then really you're not gonna live
longer right there's skepticism among
many in the mainstream scientific
community around the role that
biohackers can play in better
understanding our biology
do the risks of this
self-experimentation outweigh the
potential rewards or is there a middle
ground that could help to push the
boundaries of optimizing our health
the idea of
allowing
for
more use of experimental therapy under
informed consent in a way that
all data
must be shared
so that that we as a community can learn
from it i think that's a really exciting
idea
biohacking has become a global movement
and
we are out there asking the hard
questions and doing the things that a
lot of scientists would like to do but
they're not allowed to do because we
still have autonomy over our own bodies
and when we talk about our results when
we share them online scientists see them
and go
interesting
and then that provides fuel for studies
the problem becomes when people start
doing things which are not
evidence-based
you know for which the information
really just isn't out there
then i think obviously i you know as
with anything else it can get dangerous
you know if you don't have the
information on which to base a decision
to do something but you go ahead and do
it i mean that's risky by definition i
think somewhere in between there
is is a happy intermediate i'm a
scientist so i like to see what happens
to my body when i do x y or z but of
course i'm very careful i measure what
happens and make sure that i'm hopefully
not doing myself any harm
many of those trying to hack the aging
process are also interested in trying to
optimize their immune systems
in fact there are biohackers
experimenting with procedures such as
fecal transplants
taking someone else's poo as a medicine
in an attempt to cure a range of ills
though less extreme supermarkets and
pharmacy shells are heaving with
so-called immune boosting pills and
supplements
but is it even possible to alter how the
body responds to disease through
consuming someone else's poo or by
eating a blueberry pill
and what are the risks
the immune system is part of an
interconnected system running all the
way through our body involving all our
tissues from our skin all the way
through to our toes
and in fact the gut has one of the
largest resident populations of immune
cells in our body most of the body's
immune cells are found in the lining of
the intestine and the microbes in our
gut play a crucial role in keeping those
immune cells of our body healthy they do
that by providing with key chemical
signals that they get once they digest
the good foods that we eat so a healthy
gut microbiome is actually crucial to a
healthy immune system the immune system
is considered to be an organ
but unlike every other organ in your
body it's one where components of the
system can migrate around the body
you don't expect that with cells from
your lungs or your spleen or any other
solid organ but the beauty of the immune
system is it has a property of
immunosurveillance immunological
surveillance is when the cells of the
immune system come together to
coordinate a response to an external
threat such as disease for example your
lymph nodes the glands that swell up
when you are sick are a sign of your
immune system at work we often hear
messages encouraging us to boost our
immune system so could we just take a
pill to do that when you do meet an
infectious threat our immune response
has to react quickly to contain the
threat and eradicate it and you don't
want it to stay on because if it stays
on it's damaging and that is what
happens in allergy and autoimmune
disease which are overreactivity
of the immune response
so there is no wonder pill that's going
to restore and boost one part of the
immune response to help us be super
powered because it's also interconnected
and the risks of getting it wrong are
really quite dramatic
so instead of boosting our immune system
we should focus on supporting it
everything that we know already which is
good for our health will also benefit
our immune system
more exercise taking at regular
intervals has been shown to boost your
immune function that's been shown and
that's published data unfortunately the
modern lifestyle is not very good for
our immune system
our diets of convenience foods and fatty
foods that are low in fiber alongside
sedentary lifestyles with little
exercise high stress and not too much
sleep too much screening time all of
these combine to make our immune
response not work as it should
getting enough sleep and reducing stress
can help our immune system operate at an
optimal level and even though one
blueberry won't work miracles getting a
variety of the right foods is very
important to help your immunity you need
to be feeding up your gut microbes and
the best way to do this to make them
more diverse give them more species and
i recommend 30 different types of plant
a week which gives you all the fiber you
should need secondly you should pick
plants to eat that are high in
polyphenols these are the chemicals that
are naturally found in plants and
are actually rocket fuel for your gut
microbes so things like brightly colored
berries
strong flavors like coffee beans
dark chocolate and even red wine contain
polyphenols so if what you eat and your
gut is so important for your immune
system why are some people transplanting
other people's poo into their own
stomachs
[Music]
a fecal microbial transplant or
colloquially a poo transplant is taking
a sample of a stool from a normal person
and putting it into someone who's
unwell this has been done for several
decades for very bad infections of the
bowel like clostridium difficile and it
cures 90 of people and it's been since
starts to be used in a number of other
conditions this is a fascinating area of
research but definitely not to be tried
at home says tim
i think this is an exciting new form of
therapy but it's always best to do this
within the confines of a medical clinic
where things can be supervised and the
risk of side effects or infection is
extremely low there are some people who
take risks and do do it at home and
those risks will be multiplied
considerably there's a lot of hype about
fecal transplants and you mustn't
believe people who say that it works in
everything in everybody it certainly
doesn't and there are many failures in
the clinical trials one of the ways we
can effectively and safely manipulate
our immune responses is through
vaccination what a vaccine is doing is
essentially giving you the parts of the
germ that will stimulate the immune
response without actually getting the
full-blown infection another thing that
we can do is actually try to switch the
immune response off
for some diseases we don't want a
powerful immune response because that's
what's causing the damage
this is exactly what's done in diseases
like rheumatoid arthritis multiple
sclerosis or is also being investigated
infections like covert the good news is
whilst there's no one magic pill we can
take to optimize our immune response the
more scientists learn about how our
immune system works the more they can
develop new drug treatments and
therapies to combat a wide range of
diseases the knowledge of science is
actually leading to all sorts of
wonderful new possibilities to help
treat us and win the war against
infection
as well as optimizing our bodies many of
us are also interested in boosting our
brains in fact for centuries people have
looked for ways to increase their
intelligence concentration and
creativity through nootropics or
cognitive enhancers if you're currently
sipping on a skinny latte you're
consuming a form of nootropic right now
caffeine's a stimulant and famous for
its ability to perk you up
but so-called smart drugs are gaining
popularity there's now a huge market for
over-the-counter supplements which claim
with very little scientific evidence to
boost concentration and memory some
people go even further and seek out
prescription stimulants such as
modafinil in a bid to improve
performance at work while studying a
2017 study based on the global drug
survey an anonymous questionnaire showed
that 30 of americans had taken some kind
of smart drug in the last 12 months that
was up from 20 in 2015 and they're not
alone
large increases were reported across
europe as well
but do these drugs actually work and
what are the risks
hanukkah de uden is a cognitive
neuroscientist at the donders institute
for brain cognition and behaviour at
radboud university her lab has been
studying how the state of our brains
chemistry shapes how we act so modafinil
is in a category of drugs classed as
psychostimulants other examples are
methylphenidate and for example
amphetamine and psychostimulants act
generally in a way to enhance activity
in your dopamine system
raised levels of a neurotransmitter
called dopamine can stimulate signals in
the parts of your brain associated with
concentration and focus
it also helps to reduce hyperactive and
impulsive behaviors this is incredibly
useful for people with adhd for example
but it's also finding its way illegally
into the hands of those without a
diagnosed medical condition in some
recent studies we've looked at how
psychic stimulants affect decision
making in a young healthy population so
not
patients who are taking these
for treatment specifically we study
methylphenidate this is a drug that's
maybe better known by the brand name
ritalin or adderall and what we found
was that methylphenidate makes you
better across a number of tasks and we
think this might be the case because we
experience these tasks as less kind of
cognitively effortful
but says hanukkah taking these brain
boosting drugs without a medical
prescription is risky
all medications the risk of side effects
and there's a reason that these are
prescription drugs
so when we run a medication study for
example using circus stimulants we
really extensively screen our
participants we actually get a doctor to
sign off on prescribing people even a
single pill we often give people only a
single dose we know for example that
psychostimulants increase your heart
rate and this can pose a risk for people
with underlying heart problems like
arrhythmia that they may not even know
about
drugs don't affect everyone in the same
way drugs will help some people really
well and they will not help others at
all and this is really the holy grail of
psychiatry it's been for for decades
probably how can we predict what drugs
work for whom
hanukkah says there have been virtually
no studies on the long-term cognitive
effects of psychostimulant use in
non-patients but boosting the dopamine
levels in the brain could cause
long-term problems
so i talked about this finely tuned
balance of our brain chemistry
and when you disturb that system by
adding a lot of dopamine then the system
main response to try to regain that
balance turn down its sensitivity to
dopamine and so you could become
dependent on taking the medication to
kind of get to your normal levels of
your system
and then finally there's another risk
and this is maybe even more speculative
but i think um also very important to
think about
is that being really focused all the
time
is not necessarily the optimal state for
all situations we do know that being
super focused may actually reduce our
creativity and our openness to new ideas
or
out-of-the-box solutions
and so i think that we don't want a
society of just hyper-focused people
rather than boosting your brainpower
through medication there's growing
evidence that it can be boosted through
more natural means namely meditation and
mindfulness
so how does that work one consequence of
being human is the fact that we have
these minds that can kind of wander off
and think about all kinds of weird stuff
right this is laurie santos she's a
professor of psychology at yale and
teaches a course called the science of
well-being the research shows that the
simple act of meditating even like 10
minutes a day if you're a novice can
significantly reduce brain activation in
regions of your brain that tend to mind
wander so it's literally changing the
kind of default firing patterns of your
brain just to this simple act of
meditating so why is mind wandering not
so good
laurie says research shows that when our
mind wanders it can make us unhappy
the irony is that we're never fully
present right and the enjoyment that we
get out of simple actions in life
whether that's you know eating something
delicious or doing the dishes or talking
with a friend like we really need to be
present for that to kind of kick in
right we need to be there to savor it
and notice it and this means that this
act of mind wandering seems to
significantly decrease our well-being
over time and that's why practices like
meditation can be so powerful
meditation in a variety of different
forms at least one of the benefits is
that it kind of trains our mind to be a
little bit more present than it's
typical not only does meditation stop
the mind wandering it also builds up
more connections between parts of the
brain it effectively rewires your brain
away from mind wandering and towards the
present and the effect lasts according
to 2008 study which found people who had
practiced meditation were happier even
eight weeks later meditation doesn't
just help us enjoy life a 2013 study by
the university of california showed that
a course of meditation actually boosted
test scores it also has a host of other
benefits says lori it increases
concentration it increases
our memory over times it has lots of
physical health consequences you can see
improvements in immune function after uh
meditation and things like that um you
know these kind of markers of aging
things like telomeres like those those
kinds of markers seem to get better for
people who regularly meditate
so if there are signs that it aids your
brain power happiness immune function
and even dna would it be too much to
talk about meditation as some kind of
remedy for the human condition you know
sometimes people talk about this
question was meditation sort of a
panacea and honestly as a scientist we
usually kind of get a little worried
when we see things that have all these
benefits but meditation just seems to be
one that empirically speaking just does
have so so many benefits
so there you have it it is possible to
optimize our bodies and our brains
whilst diy fecal transplants and the use
of non-prescribed psychostimulants are
definitely not to be recommended there
are clearly other things that can help
many of us
from vaccinations to meditation to
regular old exercise
and even though living to 180 will
probably not be attainable or even
desirable as the scientific
understanding of our bodies grows the
hope is that many of us will be able to
look forward to longer healthier and
happier lives in the future
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video